Reportage d'Elyse Allard.
- Depuis plus de 10 ans,
la directive est claire
au pays : une femme
devrait boire un maximum
de 10 verres d'alcool
par semaine; un homme, 15.
Des recommandations qui
pourraient être revues à
la baisse. Selon un rapport
commandé par Santé Canada,
le risque zéro n'existe pas.
CATHERINE PARADIS, Centre canad.
dépendances et usage de subst.
- L'Organisation mondiale
de la santé, au début janvier,
a publié une recherche dans
laquelle elle indique clairement
qu'il n'y a aucune consommation
d'alcool qui soit sécuritaire
pour la santé.
- Selon le Centre canadien
sur la dépendance et l'usage
de substances, il faudrait
consommer un maximum de
1 à 2 verres par semaine pour
un risque faible sur la santé.
3 à 6 verres représenteraient
un risque modéré de développer
plusieurs cancers, comme
celui du sein ou du colon.
7 verres ou plus par semaine
augmenteraient en plus le risque
de souffrir d'une maladie
du coeur ou d'un AVC.
- Je pense être raisonnable
en étant au-dessus
de cette limite.
- Oui, je... je pense
que ça va m'inciter à faire
de plus en plus attention.
- Des experts questionnent
les conclusions du rapport.
Dr MARTIN JUNEAU, cardiologue
Institut de cardiologie de Mtl
- C'est une lecture des données
scientifiques récentent
que je trouve biaisée.
Aux États-Unis, comme le NIAAA,
un organisme qui s'appelle
le National Institute for
Alcohol Abuse and Alcoholism
recommande toujours un verre
par jour pour une femme,
deux verres par jour
pour un homme maximum.
- Santé Canada dit examiner
ce rapport. Éduc'alcool
pourrait éventuellement
changer ses directives.
- La société aussi évolue, alors
je pense qu'une actualisation,
c'est de mise.
- Selon ce qu'on peut lire
dans le rapport, l'alcool
a été la cause d'environ
18 000 décès au Canada en 2017.
Cette même année, les coûts
associés à la consommation
d'alcool au pays s'élevaient
à plus de 16,5 milliards
de dollars, soit bien plus
que les coûts directs associés
au tabac, aux opioïdes
ou au cannabis.
Ici Élyse Allar